a former police officer heavy weapons
and defense specialist his relentless
fight for justice made him a legend on
the force
James dragged off grew up in the heart
of a crime family but he managed to pull
away from this life and join the New
York Police and eventually the division
to him the most important thing in this
world is family so what would have
compelled him to join forces with Aaron
keener
[Music]
[Music]
James drag offs father was the head of a
Russian crime family so unsurprisingly
he grew up around extortion bribery and
murder he watched as a number of good
people to embed tainted by corruption
and greed their innocence lost the
family was built on crime but dragged
off chose a different path the law and
became a New York police officer however
much to his dismay he found that things
weren't so different in the force we're
eager to zoom deceit and bribes were
abundant
so he made a design personal mission to
dedicate his career and bringing down
the extortion and lies and put a stop to
it once and for all
naturally dragged off made a name for
himself with the stern and sharpshooting
ways he was beginning to accomplish
changes within his department on
in-house crime from here he began to get
noticed by recruiters and not long after
he was recruited by the strategic
homeland division he was activated along
with the first wave division agents but
instead of assisting with the quarantine
in Manhattan who was tasked with helping
the remaining correctional officers on
Rikers Island the dollar fluid made it
here too and the dwindling guard prisons
due to sickness meant they required
extra support at this time but as the
virus spread throughout the city prison
riots began to get out of control and
communication to Rikers Island was lost
before he was stationed on Rikers Island
drag offers already showing signs of
frustration and of being disenchanted
with the division their biggest
challenges are deciding what country to
import their nannies from which divorce
and immigration lawyers to hire so what
you're saying is Silver Spoons and
detached from reality would be free from
corruption check that side of the street
in his eyes
the twisted morals of his criminal
family and the crooked police force lies
and manipulation and somehow managed to
creep its ways into the division ranks
he was beginning to realize that even
the best of us can be turned and that
extortion is everywhere money is power
the rich will being taken care of while
the poor will lift struggling to survive
fast forward to Rikers Island the prison
warden had made the call for all staff
to leave the island this was the last
straw of the drag off not everyone low
risk inmates have already been released
but the rest will have to remain in
their cells it's for everyone's safety
we can't ensure their transition into
society I'm afraid I can't let you do
that it's not your call to make
agent you have a direct order to escort
me off the island my orders are to serve
the people it's a shame I got distracted
doing my job and wasn't here in time to
save you wait what are you doing Hey
drag off killed the warden and freed the
prisoners he wasn't prepared to just
leave him there to stuff too dear to my
selves
he was mocked his rogue but before he
lived Rikers Island he grabbed the guard
keys and handed them to Larry Barrett
[Music]
sometime past a second wave of division
agents was activated in New York they
launched an attack on the record
stronghold and managed to put a name to
their leader
Larry Barrett the remaining workers were
in a state of disarray infighting had
begun as gang leaders fought amongst
themselves to become the new Rikers
Alito dragged off received a visit by
Rikers member who knew him from the
prison I was two cells over when you
through the wardens keys to Barrett hope
you're not looking for a handout
nah ain't like that I thought you'd like
to hear about an opportunity I'm
listening Barrett took a bullet or ten
there's a lot of internal conflict so
not sure I'm the right guy just come by
and say hello
I think you'll like us we already owe
you
I'm sure at first he decided to go and
see what he had to work with and what he
found was a group of district people who
simply wanted to survive he saw these as
his people his family I watched how this
country responded to calls from help
from those in need discarding them to
come to the aid of man with memes we
showed them we stormed their castles we
took from them what they took from us we
through those rich bastards out of their
ten houses and we built something from
the ruins a community no a family God be
proud family first villain Kenneth he
taught me a lot but not that he meant to
I watched as he bent mentors will how he
corrupted people around him changing
good to bad the innocent to guilty
the family he built was one of crime of
extortion of bribery Oh murder I chose
the law and all I saw was a different
side of the same coin
police corrupt thugs taking petty bribes
division huh
delusional killers of the highest order
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
you yeah you're criminals I am too we
all are but you didn't deserve what they
did to you so now we'll take what we can
it's time to ring in a new era drag off
was able to bring the Rikers crew
together the in-house fighting stopped
under his guidance they had structure
and they were carving out a territory
that they could call home
after months of babysitting the rich
drag off had gone full circle and was
taken from him in order to build up
supplies for his new family
the Ryker ranks were starting to swell
from the joining of local gangs who
desperate families who was struggling to
survive alone with the Rikers they had
security food and the supplies to last
them a lifetime after being left for
dead on the prison island things were
start to look pretty good
the drag off successes were starting to
get recognized outside of the group and
eventually he received a visit from a
certain rogue agent Aaron Tina I'm gonna
there you go some of these are gonna be
hard to find some bad do you specialize
chemicals and viral cultures though
don't take some time I'm patient but I'm
job number one unless you want to start
experiencing staff loss
[ __ ] you keener these people are family
just think of me as a second cousin if
that makes it easier I won't and it
doesn't but I'll get the [ __ ] on your
list with the condition that you leave
us alone loaded at the pier
I'll give times and locations for
deliveries don't worry I don't think it
worth your while
drag off business all that interested be
working with kena but he understands the
value of keeping him on his good side
but in saying that perhaps he took too
long
well maybe kena just wanted to show what
he was capable of yeah
it's true we lost a lot of good people
people I consider family Teeter happened
and unless we play ball he'll keep
happening that guy let's go what the
[ __ ] cabron I don't like this any more
than you but this is an opportunity for
us and it'll keep us in the good graces
of a powerful ally first things first
we're moving downtown we're gonna take
it enclave in the heart of the financial
district itself
what's an enclave god dammit Ron shut
the [ __ ] up drag off in the Rikers
proceeded to storm Wall Street they
shifted their entire operation to lower
Manhattan again taking from the rich and
stockpiling vast amounts of food weapons
body armor and ammunition he was able to
set up his black market operations with
people who had the resources to trade
could visit this would also help with
acquiring some of the more unusual
pieces from kinas list however keen was
done to grow impatient you realize that
moving our entire operation itself takes
time don't you do I look like a man who
cares about your problems I care about
one thing the delivery of the supplies I
asked for you'll get them this should
have hard to find you got 24 hours so I
don't get a delivery by then I'll make
what happened too heavy looks downright
Pleasant compared to the rest of your
crew wait I'm sure you'll figure it out
don't let me come back
kinas list included biohazard materials
and items that would require chemists to
prepare because of this who wasn't able
to complete the order on time as
punishment kena killed iruka's member
heavy controlled dragged off that he'll
continue eliminating refuse members if
you didn't deliver reluctantly dragged
off complied and helped keenan with
various other tasks for the sake of his
new family Gregor was present with Kino
when he first met division agent Theo
Parnell he was there hiding ready to
shoot if Parnell didn't agree to join
his side
KYNA ordered dragged off along with
fellow rogue agents 4v and Connelly a
vehicle chica and Theo panel to assault
the JTF base of operations and lawmen
entered he assisted in taking up the JTF
guards on site while calmly planted
Tina's new bio weapon the division
agents arrived from Washington DC and
investigated the attack while there they
found evidence pointing directly to
James dragged off along with his fellow
rogue agent two co-conspirators which
proved they were the ones behind the
attacks after further investigation it
was determined that they were in fact
working with kina over the course of
time dragged off was tracked down and
found to be residing in the financial
district where he was running his
black-market operation in an attempt to
retrieve penis supplies the division
stormed the district they were met by
Dutchess and a group of ruckus the
division dealt with Dutchess in the
Rikers and proceeded to claim the
supplies pushing through the rugged
defenses the division managed to destroy
the APC and made it to the stock
exchange building where drag off was
waiting the division fought on and
killed drag off as well as two of his
lieutenants dragged off smartwatch was
retrieved by the division and handed to
fail out on their return shield use us
to assist in locating Aaron kena the
division continued through to the Pierre
wiki no supplies we're waiting
I actually feel for dragged off he
removed himself from a situation where
he'd grown up surrounded by crime and
murder to instead do good only to find
himself in a setting that was surrounded
in the corruption of the police force
still he fought on to put it into it and
he made a name for himself to the point
of being recruited by the division but
yet again in his eyes was placed in a
position with the elites of society who
given preference over everyone else what
happened on Rikers Island caused him to
snap
obviously in search from a young age for
a group that he could call family and a
group that could meet his morals he
found what he was looking for in the
Rikers he was attempting to lead them
down a Robin Hood sort of path taken
from the rich and giving to the ones
left helpless and abandoned by the
government and what we can tell from the
comms he actually seemed to be
straightening the Rikers up to a certain
extent another interesting piece of the
puzzle that dragged off story Brinks is
the original story of how the Rikers
escaped from the prison Island has been
rectified in the division one it was
rumored that Larry Barrett was able to
free the prisoners because the warden
had a bit of a thing for her and when
stuff was going down the warden a plan
to escape would Larry on a barge he'd
organized but Larry killed him is dead
taken the guard keys I guess she didn't
bother correcting this rumor because it
more than likely helped her get into a
position of power with the ruckus anyway
what do you think to drag off deserve
what happened to him was it just another
victim of errant kinas mission thank you
very much for watching I'm hoping to get
into Vivian Conley next I'm still
missing a ton of info on her but I have
a feeling this may not be collectible at
this stage
possibly to be released in a future
update thanks again for watching and
I'll catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]